this week's videos are sponsored by hello
freshmore on them after the reaction
people hello citizens of the reject Nation
it's me Tera Eric s alongside this guy Andrew
flash Cordon wow we're watching Rise of
the Planet of the Apes and I haven't seen
any of them not a one have you I've seen
one of them apparently it's the best one
the Tim Burton one from 2001 Tim Burton
made a Planet of the Apes movie what did
get out of here oh my gosh you guys make sure
that you like you comment you also ring the
bell also thanks to prea for helping us
edit down these videos we appreciate you
so much and we call you super sexy if you join
patreon you get you get sexy and you get super
over there and you can syn up with your own copy
watch the whole planet of the apes with me and
this guy with the flash with the flash with the
Gordon with the Flash Gordon also Greg and John
offer exclusive highlights and watch alongs
over there patreon so get with it get ready
do you have any news for the people anything we
should say before we start Flash Gordon the only
thing I know is that James Franco is in this and
that uh Matt Reeves directed the other two that
are after this the director of the Batman so I'm
looking forward to that once we get past this one
that's all cool lovely piece of information
you know that he's the info book you guys a
little bit you know it all right we're ready
we're going to watch it in three three two
[Music] one
[Music] cool oh no are they hunting I better not
be I'm not liking the start me neither no no no
no no no I hate it leave them alone oh my God
I hate it oh no no had 2 minutes in I'm already
so sad oh my God okay the Rise of the Planet of
the Apes better mean that they rise and they kill
all of those people I was going to say we humans
suck sometimes oh God I hate it it hurts my heart
so much poor baby a really don't like that okay
I'm so on the ape side as of right now yeah me
too which one's this number nine yeah on the
bright eyes color this is unbelievable oh
wow how many moves was that 20 doc what you what
are you giving her hey give me that video that was
amazing full cognitive recovery been working on
this for 5 and 1/2 years the date is clear we're
ready St all I need is your approval for human
trial o that never works out well in movies yes
keep your personal emotions out of it these people
invest in results not dreams here she's tasking at
what is called the Lucas Tower to move the tower
from Peg to Peg without placing a larger block
on top of a smaller block huh she wasn't able
to complete the puzzle at all we gave her what
we call alz 112 a gene therapy that allows the
brain to create its own cells wow I need that
right we call it the cure to alzheimer's oh wow
this is giving me some deep deep blue sea Vibes
yeah she's got stage fright is that what it is
although I'd rather give it to apes and a shark
totally ooh yikes also probably causes
aggression scary know right I'm
good I just quit we're ready to
move on to the next phase uh human
trials here you go BR eyes it's your
favorite fizzy soda come on good girl no
no they're going to can don't do it why
that's Jesus oh
yeah oh no uhoh the tranquilizer that's
what happens when you make them smart and
it's funny cuz they're already so intelligent
to begin with yeah there have been absolutely
no side effects associated with 112 oh my God I
hope she breaks into the meeting first noticed
that in chimp 9 hence her nickname bright
eyes you'll see when we bring her in yeah
bring her in that way is not going to be good
this therapy can be used to treat a wide range
of brain disorders whoa dang acrobatic we are
confident that you will vote to approve human Tru
[Music] trial oh my God oh my God no oh baby poor
baby why'd you have to go the lethal route God you
know they have freaking Whatchamacallit put them
to sleep drugs use tranquilize tranquilizer Mr
Jacobs I am begging you these are animals with
personalities with attachments I run a business
not a petting zoo find the most cost effective
way to put those Apes down oh God they've taken
the 112 Bo of rejected your proposal they've
chosen to advance other programs start again
in molecular development find a way to get
there before someone else does Franklin they
carry small suppos been pregnant when we brought
her in she wasn't being aggressive she was just
being protective oh my gosh uh my brother-in-law
works for security he W me out in a second you
want me to take it home I can't take care of a
monkey he's not a monkey he's an ape just for
a couple days until I find a sanctuary that's all
I need you started this program bro take the ape
Jacobs made me put down the other 12 oh my God
I hate it he not going to be able to do it yeah
I'd have too much Humanity in me to do it how's he
doing well he has good days and bad days oh that's
okay so his dad has Alzheimer's that's
why he works on it got it makes sense
why it's so personal to today's the
day right you thought I'd forget you
have a big test today right chemistry
jeez that's sad want to see something
what oh it's so cute so cute kneel down damn
you imagine what was going through his mind
it's like yes we got the Breakthrough like
not only for just people in general but his
father no it's that the baby this is what happens
when you become a parent you never get to sleep
again also too it's probably
missing its mother like crazy
yeah little dude has a
cold my car keys where'd you put them
dad you don't you don't drive anymore
why why don't you feed them
can you do that of course I
can he's so cute oh my gosh I love him so much
if they would stay that size I would consider
getting an ape but then also there's the flip
side like they deserve to be in the wild too like
H and they get so big that they could physically
hurt you if they stayed that size and it wasn't
bad to take them out of the wild I would would
consider getting one that size cuz that might
be the cutest thing I've ever seen bright eyes
right away Caesar displayed signs of heightened
intelligence wow so I kept him brought my work
home I thought the other Handler said he was
going to find a sanctuary yeah maybe he decided to
continue his research on him because he had the he
was Advanced also the movie has to happen too yeah
Caesar was signing up to 24 words these are my f I
love tracking shots yeah it's a this is a great
warer Caesar was completing puzzles and models
designed for children8 years and up oh he's going
to want out at some point I maintain my hypothesis
that a the Green in his eyes indicates that the
alz-112 was passed genetically from mother to
son oh love that like how he drew him green
since he's ends up becoming the Green Goblin
and Spider-Man you knew this was coming Pete and
plays chess pretty well damn I can't even play
chess oh uhoh Sor I can't do this anymore
he belongs in a home there is no way for
him to live gosh yeah oh thanks yeah
it's Alzheimer's is just now he has to
be pressured with a point to when does
he experiment on his father which is
you know not going to be recommended
but when you're at your Last Resort
right oh yeah I knew it I mean oh
you you I hope I hope it works yeah
me too he might also have like that
but what I thought to be aggression
as a side effect but it may have just
been her protecting her baby so who
knows oh oh Dad got up on his own yeah
what's he doing is he playing the piano
downstairs with that yeah but are there any side
effects right I'm sure there are there has to be
wow he remembers to play [Music] mhm oh he
wants to ride a bike oh did the Chain Break
oh he wants to go play uh it's not the best
idea you're safer in the house oh [Music] no
I don't foree you needing more than one
treatment a month something amazing is
that you'll need a blood test and a scan and
the doal we have to be carefully will he get
in trouble though if they even if it find
that it worked oh yeah I mean absolutely
he won't be able to well where's Caesar I
want to see him can't use the results but
yeah uhoh no I know but not supposed
to have an ape outside Cesar daddy oh
God no oh my gosh no enough oh my God doesn't
matter with you I sh that animal anywhere near my
house or my kids again is not dangerous oh my god
dude Jesus effing I told you not to go out without
us [Music] a how bad is it I don't [Applause] know
oh I hate seeing them in enclos Ms like that yeah
serve to be free in the wild going to go see his
like take him to see his it'll be over soon and we
can go get a treat I'm thinking ice cream oh I see
so Andy Circus is working with her now and then
they work together on The Jungle Book years later
cuz he directed her in that oh told him to sign
handful of things basic things what's he saying
nothing you're really hot so when do you think
we should come back well you won't need to come
back the stitches are dissolvable watch out for
signs of infection fever redness hope for a fever
and redness so we can come back what's she saying
now get her phone number he thinks that you and I
should have dinner together yes he's the ultimate
setup guy I mean look how adorable he is he's a
good wingman Caesar come on did it work good to
see you again Caroline it worked I'm taking an
ape with me to the next hot vet I built a pretty
good home for Caesar here now he won't stay this
way for long he's going to soon grow into a large
powerful animal yeah how's he been doing okay fine
I think I love chimpanzees I'm also afraid of them
never anyone a so cute can we at least give him
some open space I know a place right across the
bridge the Redwoods well the good thing is the
company never knew about the baby he doesn't
need a leash you'll be fine come on just to be
safe come on come on Caesar probably a good idea
I have never seen an ape on a leash interesting
it's a first thing is he's probably so strong if
he sees something he's just going to break there's
no way he can like hold it back true you cannot
leave my sight I'll never find you again what's
this what's she doing do he want to hold your hand
he's asking your permission it's a suffocating
gesture it's okay come on Caesar off you
go uh oh God how are they going to
find him again I guess he'll come
just have to come back back he
I mean he is in his domain now f
wow cool GNA want to go back to the house
after this as much as he loves them probably
not whoa that was a cool transition [Music]
yeah oh [Music] wow he's a fully-fledged
adult yeah it's going to say can he live in
the the house at this age well no I think
that's what she was warning him about
that it's going to become dangerous and
probably Impossible 5 years later but
he doesn't have clothes so maybe so it
was three years originally now five so
it's eight years total so they've been
dating for 5 years now long time it's
like I've been replaced what's going on
buddy it's like look I was your wing man now you
got to find me a woman yeah right is that that a
chimpanzee God if they let this dog loose
and it hurts him no I don't want it stay
back oh God that's scary let's go you getting
in Cesar damn he is big you okay pal you're
not a pet I'm your father yep that's what
Dad means this is where you were born your
mother was here with other chimpanzees my
mother's dead so is mine Caesar it's okay
me too I had no idea that the effects had been
transferred vertically from his mother but since
then he's been displaying incredible signs of
intelligence I designed the 112 for repair but
Caesar's gone way beyond that jeez here's his
IQ from last year since then it's doubled my
father was gone this drug brought him back what
about Cesar what do he fit in with us all I'm
saying is this is a good thing Cesar eat your
food yeah it's hard to eat when you're mad and
depressed yeah so he's degrading even with meds
I'm wondering well it's it's been 5 years system
has found a way to fight the 112 virus so that
it can't deliver its therapy oh oh okay father's
disease is going to return with a Vengeance
dang it was a trial run so well he got a good
five years I mean that's better than nothing
yeah I agree I would sign up for it yeah I'll
take five years over nothing oh no where's he
going oh Caesar's Gonna Save him did what who
just leaves a door open on a vehicle like that
dude's doing a car wash but still oh come on
buddy and the keys are in
it oh my goodness okay get out of there
get out of that oh great crazy guy I said
get out of my oh he's going to go
in protective mode yeah that's his
grandfather and also that guy tried hitting
him with a bat years ago yeah he probably
PTSD this is your problem you
made oh no oh God he can break
out of that window if he really
up okay just stay right there oh
yep oh ooh
yikes oh boy woo oh [Music] yikes
oh you're not outrunning him no
now I'm afraid Caesar's going to actually kill him
oo ouch
daddy oh no okay now he's not going
to be able to live you're going to
have to let him go B to the wild if
Animal Control isn't yeah there's no
way well it was the same thing with the
mom at the beginning was in protective
mode over the baby yep hey hey take that
thing off of him we take that thing off
of him Brian Cox wow he didn't know he
was in this Cesar going to be okay let's
just see what it's like inside okay
yeah I'm sorry I a no trusting Animal
Control okay looks pretty nice and big but
it's still still we need let him go to the
Wilderness yeah I mean at least this is closer
to the Wilderness than his room yeah but but he
wants to be he wants to be with his family yeah
he hasn't spent any time with other chips oh we
used to that he'll be a little skittish at first
but we'll integrate him hey Draco Maloy is it Tom
Felton his name right let's do some paperwork
oh and make sure you lock that door when you
come in I mean it's it's almost like a picture
he's seeing with him eventually his dad is going
to have to go to at home too yeah but he's going
to freak out I feel like when he sees that James
Franco is not going to be able to stay with him
Caesar going to be okay I don't like it stay here
now why are you leaving me not going home
right now our experience so long you drag
out the goodbyes the harder it is sign that later
oh jeez there's so many wonderful human beings in
this oh like this is what I get for
protecting grandpa just call ahead
before you do God now I'm like they're
doing some weird sneaky [__] that's
why he's like call ahead I don't like it yeah
seriously well that was a odd line hey down
here yeah he's kept in that
cage stupid monkey oh my God I
hate everyone it makes my stomach
[Applause]
hurt [Music] on okay this is tragic so I hate
them all and my stomach hurts now father's
immune system continues to reject the 112
virus rendering the gene therapy obsolete
his health is deteriorating and the disease
is progressing rapidly 10 years you've been
running gens this how many drugs have come down
the pipeline that could save millions of lives
the alz 112 it's like not this again the 112 is
dangerous will and it doesn't work I treated my
father with it it does work worked for 5 years
I've already developed a virus strain that I
think will be more aggressive just let me test
it you're wasting my time like how all he cares
about is the bottom line my father didn't
just recover he improved you mean increased
intelligence it's not conclusive but yes I
want you to start testing the revised 112 on
jimp ASAP you start talking about Benjamins
people start listening at least if they work
for corporations like you could sell it as is
and be like it's only a 5year fix again that's
still better than nothing but you're going to
have those people that said you didn't tell me
it was only for 5 years go on don't you know
food when you see it oh my God I hate these
people I cannot wait till the Apes rise and
kill them all yeah now come on everybody do
it hey I hate it my God I can't wait for that guy
to die immediately clearly it was
tera's favorite character in Harry
Potter oh my God some of these scenes are so
painful I know oh my god really are they wanted
us on the side of Caesar and the Apes they they've
done it they've done it very well really from the
top oh that's his window at home good call
[Music] a can hear the children outside
tighten your Mas pass me the 113 oh so this
is the next evolution of the drug pressure
steady uh oh he's looking around like
he does not like this and and he's about
to oh oh Franklin get your mask
on got it oh did he get affected yeah okay uhoh
I feel like that yeah even just
one second of breathing that in
might
is he the Pariah of the group God I'm sure
he's the alpha and it's going to teach him
a lesson I meant Caesar the pariaa
oh yeah oh don't rip his clothes off
oh yeah but the advantage Caesar
has over them is he's way more
intelligent
oh like the biting of the [Music]
fingers
ow she gonna write Jacob that the guy's name Jacob
Jacobs some one scared me yeah it's the eyes
intelligence results are remarkable no adverse
effects Apes have amazingly strong immune
systems all right keep an eye on it okay uhoh
you got the virus buddy yeah he's definitely been
affected in some way oh yeah he he definitely has
crap oh this looks like King Lou in
Jungle they're communicating yes I
do oh no what the fudge are they doing
I hate these guys so much no like smart
ape okay oh so pretend to be dumb yeah don't
sign in front of them oh delivering to where
James Franco work [__] I wonder if Caesar's
going to find out because he he remembers that
he worked there cuz he drove in there and if
he can get on there then he could maybe warn
dad about what's going on or I don't know or
do you think he's going to feel betrayed that
he does this you hurt show me GH tell that guy
to leave I hate him sometimes the new kid on
the Block gets picked on that's [__] yeah
yeah I'm taking him out of here right now not
without a court order you're not he's not yours
anymore if I find out he's been mistreated in any
way I'll have this place shut down I feel like
they're going to mistreat him now more for like
no we're not going home right now but I'm going
to get you out of here I promise this visit's
over I can't wait for the rise of the apes
to take over I this is like killing my soul
you oh he doesn't even want the window up
anymore he doesn't want to be oh no oh he
feels abandoned oh poor Cesar well he can now
communicate with the orangutang and build a plan
maybe oh he's going to figure it
out he's like maybe if I let this one loose fck
out right he's looking at the hardware this this
shell be a lot easier to escape what's his name
name is Cornelia oh my God don't get too close
this one scared me have to death that big guy
is called Maurice I'll show you something fun
oh my God re oh they got drink they're having a
party here wow oh God why would he do that that
one's a pain in the ass think he special
or something uh oh he wants the bottle cap
you saw oh okay yeah yeah yeah oh he's going
to yeah he grabbed it from his Pock from his
pocket I feel like he saw him do that and
that's why he come on guys let's get out
of here I think he grabbed out of his pocket
yeah I hope so we didn't see it but I assume
they didn't give us that pickup of it going
in there unless yes ah oh it's a knife got
it see why they don't like smart Apes oh
yeah you let this guy out you've uh got a
golden ticket out of there yep let Buck Go
fullon Buck like uh dude just do what you
do hey what you met at me I just let you out oh my
God I was just charging up
oh what is that the
alpha oh you no longer the alpha here
sir oh okay we're all friends
fall in line buddy you're in
charge I relinquished my power yeah I
have a feeling just from the way Caesar
like scratched off the window like he's
not even going to want to come back to
James Franco anyways oh right I mean they'll
probably have a bonding scene but he's he's
going to want to live in the wilderness in the
wild and just find that's where he needs to be
anyways it is that just die yeah looks like it
oh no hey you know what it it's really sad but
at least he got five extra years with him it's
better than nothing what's going on here we 113
trials no we have to analyze koba's Blood
Work First Franklin knows this where is he
that's sick for 2 days ooh he's been sick yeah
okay we agreed to test sparingly on one subject
and that one subject is stunning oh now he's
rushing it oh crap every test result verifies
its effect no more tests can't rush it we're
dealing with a drug that is worth more than
everything else we are developing combined you
make history I make money money money money yeah
so go upstairs and deal with the money don't
come down here play with science sir we will
proceed without you yeah you can't leave all
those Apes behind and your research like Duck
the hell are you oh no I'm surprised this name
didn't move I can't say our proof they're not
people you know you going to let them go or not
Caesar's not going to want to go with him though
Caesar hey come on nope he doesn't want to go
come on we're going home come On's get out of
here I can't abandon my
brothers h
ch's training him yeah but it looks
like that but got to get our product
placement see I would just mad scientist in and
like strategically take the chocolate
chips out they're like oh okay so you
want you want a million dollars for
this cookie that now looks like Swiss
cheese together strong
[Music] strong all right get in there
Alpha I'll teach him to be smart D it Rodney
you leave the hose out in the atrium again what
no oh he saw that number oh yeah that's a good
point he's definitely going to know the code
great ah good job
buddy like he's coming up with a
complete elaborate plan here that's
the chain he was looking at like when
he was earlier oh it opens the window
wow ow he's going to make them smarter cool
he's like I can't make them smart I need the
drug to do it so we were on the right track
like he's going to make them smart he just
needed the drug uhoh yeah well he's already
got it so it doesn't it's not going to him
oh wow he's just going to like make them all
smart there we go if they're all with the same
intelligence as him that place is going down oh
for sure they know how to break out form a team
get the hell out of there oh let's go also
hopefully kill this guy oh you are so done
forth okay this is where the phone
comes out and this is turning into
a viral video is this the the
scientist that she's going to
did he pass away looks like blood
is on the yeah on the handle handle
like oh God I I got him imagine the
neighbor I mean sneezed all blood all
over the neighbor too right that's why I'm like
oh if it's a virus I assume that neighbor could
get it too what the hell I'm not liking
his chances of survival I'm loving the
chances of him dying and I can't wait to
see him yeah sorry Malfoy you might have
survived Harry Potter but not this one
what the hell do you think you're doing
huh wonder if they emptied the guns
if they had access to them that's
it see what you get get back oh God
no I hate it okay come on guys no no
no get him Caesar come on
yeah yes take your stinking
BL off me you damn dirty a here the dirty one no
yeah yes he talked get
it does that mean he can talk now for
like fully no more signing I don't
know all right here we go Apes [Music]
rise yeah yeah you don't
got enough bullets for that
buddy oh
I mean yeah he wasn't like terribly that's why
Caesar was like hey he wasn't the bad one yeah
he was just he was the he was horrible oh there
goes the hose part yeah you get it now buddy oh
water and electricity don't work well together
somebody's going to get [Music] electrocuted
later bro oh he's goner yeah I was going to
say water and electricity don't work well
together whoa that's such a cool shot
that's awesome Caesar Caroline have
You' been up to Caesar's room oh
did Caesar leave him a no look in
the refrigerator something's missing
no one's answering oh yeah they're
going to go there and go well oh that's
a great shot you don't see that every day
not a good look for his his genis research
but oh and he's finding the [Music]
evidence what happened she spoke
it's going to say how do I describe
it oh oh God they're in the trees
oh wow that looks amazing like if
someone mowing all these trees from above
wow that's a great tracking shot the
sfpd tell them we got a fatality what
is it I know where he's headed yeah
yeah oh man this is just I shall get
revenge on my mother big old repeat of
five years ago except with 50 more was
eight eight years right or eight
years ago it was three and then
five plus an orangutang ah we shall let you
all free Franklin is dead he was exposed to
the 113 it does something to people that it
doesn't do to oh okay so it's not good for
humans that's cuz remember he was like trying
to make the strain stronger so it would last
but that obviously is causing death boy you are
not going to have a good day at work sir for it
now
whoa oh I can't believe he got away helicopter
okay just with one jump he knocked that puppy down
I mean he's a big boy yeah all right obviously I
don't want any good human beings Hur right but
at the same time I don't mind all the Apes be
and monkeys being freed right they're being
lit these apes are smer than you think we've
got to kill the leader yeah I feel like with
their intelligence they're probably not going
to try to harm humans which is maybe why that
guy got out and maybe just try to free their
own possibly oh God no ah uh this is not going
to well for the driver he's going to get out
okay yeah this is what we didn't get at the
beginning yeah you you let him out buddy or
you die okay let him out you're free you're
free all right you can have him I'll go find
a cat somewhere oh no they can take those cars
I guarantee they brought one oh smart okay all
right [Music] woo oh damn oh
cool yes you are superior you're on the bridge
they're trying to get to the Redwoods where'
she say they're trying to get to to the Redwoods
oh where he yeah initially took yeah yeah yeah
what's the status of the mounted units Good To
Go sir all right as soon as I reach you seriously
just let them go there I'm like they're saying
push North but what are they going to do try
to kill him north side we're going to push them
right to no problem we're ready for them North
side's lock they'll never get through here God
no I hate it just let them go they're too smart
they've got a plan I hope you okay them I shoot
fish in a barrel good no not good okay there's
a bus right in front of that thing you don't
understand get off this bridge now this is an
evacuation get out all civilians clear please
confirm yeah but I'm the star of this movie so
I can do what I want yeah maybe James Franco
will'll find a way to help them so they don't
get killed or they take over that bus yeah I'm
I'm hoping like because there is a Humanity side
to Caesar I'm hoping James Franco can somewhat
appeal to him although obviously I do want them
to get to the Redwoods yeah just unharmed all
of them they going to climb up great yes woo
oh that's so cool damn that is high up it's
great oh oh and Below oh smart love it oh yes
and they're going to slaughter all
right what can you do to help hey hey
hey be careful
okay no no no oh buddy
ow I hate
it yeah get him oh yeah you better watch
out oh no no no oh I just feel bad for
the horse yeah I know I think Buck will
just take care of him know take care of
him there we go yeah that's good I'm
okay with that it's the best possible
outcome I he just hitting him nothing was
happening you the no gosh dang it get
the helicopter yeah man or move quicker
and somehow get that helicopter
where are they I can't see them
but they see you I hope
so oh there's a couple big ones yeah okay the
bus that's what I was talking about
before okay this is great use it as
cover oh
yeah whoa that's awesome so smart
oh just Ram it into them too going
to ram right through hopefully they
run out of bullets don't have time to
[Applause]
reload oh damn yeah surprise attack
okay all right here we go I was smart
that was smart distract with the boss
surprise attack oh no go go go oh my
gosh go take down that helicopter not
the machine gun oh God just mowing them
[Music] down oh he's going to
throw that okay are you going
to be able to hit it wo [Applause]
yes oh my my gosh Here Comes Buck oh
oh sorry buddy damn yeah oh God you
are so done you are done Zoo but I
hope Buck gets out I don't know if he's going to
oh oh dang dang it sacrifice
for the leader oh poor buddy oh
buddy God so
tragic help me no throw that damn
helicopter in the water yeah okay Koba
[Music] yeah
see you yeah but Caesar and James Franco at least
have to have their [Music] goodbye Cesar
he's got to say goodbye to him it's his
dad oh not you Koba don't touch my dad boy Cesar's
the alpha you got to listen listen to him back off
buddy that's still his dad at the
end of the day ROM man I'm sorry
this is my fault this has to stop
this isn't the way you know what
they're capable of if you come home
I'll protect you this is his home
now oh Cesar is
home that's a great
reaction I love that respect level the
alpha has for him now or the previous Alpha
rather [Music] yeah we bow to you [Music] sir
that's kind of how we started to in the jungle
on the jungle wow all right holy tamale D that was
so emotional too no it was really really good uh I
obviously I was joking earlier when I I said the I
mean I've only seen like I said earlier I've only
seen one apes film The the Tim Burton one and
I was joking everyone's favorite because I know
everyone talks so much crap about I didn't hate
planed oh ah sorry I'll get back to it in a sec
is this the neighbor who the bit oh you can see
his finger the neighbor cuz M he was coughed on
yes we know he's been infected and is he going to
be crashing a plane yeah what's happening blood
uh you got your comeuppence what does that
mean it's going to spread like to other like
the yeah I feel like cuz he's he's going to get
on the plane and then if he has if he spreads it
other people I mean now that there's blood on the
ground and he probably will be spreading it Aloha
reject Nation Greg here so many of you guys know
most of my days are a couple of hours of filming
and then most of the time it's dedicated to like
editing and a bunch of other computer work often
accumulating to like 10 to 12 hours a day and on
top of that comfort food is like my life's biggest
Vice but as many of you also know working out and
getting healthier has been a massive component for
me this year in particular so in this Whirlwind
I have found myself a perfect Ally for quick
healthy meals America's number one meal kit
a meal kit that I have subscribed to prior to
ever agreeing and working with them so yes this
is a genuine testimony and that is of course for
hello fresh and hellofresh isn't just about ease
about bringing health and flavor to your doorstep
in this holiday season forget about the stress of
planning meals for your health conscious friends
friends like me who will breathe down the back
of your neck being like I can't eat that that's
unhealthy so hello fresh I'm looking forward
to hosting holiday dinners that are not only
delicious but also cater to Healthy Lifestyles
best part the variety it is incredible I'm
pescatarian so they have these delicious meals
just like Dijon onion crunch salmon over lemon
broccoli spaghetti and for my more plant-based
days the vegan Maple carrot power bowls they
aren't just meals they're culinary Adventures I
learned the word culinary during a long day the
last thing I want to do is spend a while cooking
and that's where helloof Fresh's 15minute meals
are a LIF saer they're quick nutritious and Oho
tasty perfect from my non-stop lifestyle so why
not join me in making this holiday season both
health conscious and delicious with hellofresh
with over 45 recipes and seasonal add-ons to
choose from every week there's always something
new to try and here's something to cheer about go
to hellofresh.com reex free and use code reject
free for free breakfast for life is that accurate
that sounds way too good to be true there's no
way that can be true go to hellofresh.com reex
free and use code reject free for free breakfast
breakfast for Life One breakfast item per box
as long as your subscription is active tag your
hellofresh creations with # hellofresh piic
and at hellofresh and let's cook up some fun
and healthiness reject Nation remember it's
America's number one meal kit well what I was
saying earlier is I didn't I mean I acknowledge
it's not a great film not this is a very good
film I'm talking about the the Tim Burton one but
I didn't hate it as much as everyone else but also
I didn't have the history that I'm sure many other
people did that being said I really enjoyed this
this film there was such an emotional attack oh
Patrick Doyle he actually did Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire the music the first three were John
Williams the fifth and sixth were Nicholas Hooper
the seventh and eighth were Alexander desplat
I know everyone wanted to know that piece of
information but uh obviously the connection I was
making was with Tom Felton who we will see here
in the cast is Draco Maloy the nicest character we
got in this film um but uh I really did love this
film um I I appreciated the emotional attachment
we got with Caesar just all the Apes and General I
mean I think at least unless you're a terrible
human being I mean just feeling you know Tom
Felton there you go uh just what the Apes had to
go through just from the very beginning to just
uh in general and then I loved going through
Caesar's journey and then Andy cir is such an
amazing job with the map as Caesar God he was so
good um but just the journey we went through with
Caesar just from from being a little baby to you
know full-fledged adult uh it was just it was an
emotional Incredible Journey and I just loved
uh uh just his relationship with James Franco
to then you know getting going to that awful
shelter whatever it was H the the the ape house
or whatever it was um and then just seeing how
treacherous like seeing what his kind has to go
through and then just gave him a different Outlook
and I also thought it was interesting too because
he had such Humanity in him um that oh Jak kuto
I believe that Jak kuto was also so Ed was a mon
and baseball monkey movie anyways um I know I have
all these weird facts in me too many referen too
many references but um yeah I just thought the the
the distinction between like um what Caesar went
through from like he grew up with humans uh like
like a like a human whereas these Apes like they
grew up as Apes well not as Apes should in terms
of you know just as normal AP normally without
the human without the human component interactions
and then they got the intelligence whereas he was
born with that so I like seeing that distinction
and then he like technically taught them and I
just thought that was such a cool twist uh just
really good storytelling but I'll get more into
it what did you think of the I feel like at the
top when they set us up with them in the cages
and us being like Oh we we hate it so much that we
want them to get out and then finally the reveal
at the end of them actually being back in nature
because in the beginning you kind kind of have a
thought a little bit like they're being tested on
we we really don't like it but also what's going
to be safest for them because have they has all of
their nature instincts gone away because they've
been in this Zoo they've been tested on will they
be able to survive in the wild but we see now
that I think in them learning what Caesar brought
with his intelligence that Apes separate are very
weak but Apes together are very strong that they
wouldn't have been able to survive without that
message which I really like that Caesar delivered
that and I mean the the medication the medication
the virus uh alz helped him but then also helped
all of them even though it made it it it turned
into a bad thing which is is not great that it it
spread to humans because he developed it a little
too quickly um which is not great I I saying on
their side I'm like you guys should have stuck to
alz 112 and sold it as a fiveyear remedy instead
of pushing it to be uh 113 and Lasting forever
I don't understand why you could of course make
money off that but again we are in the reference
of of a movie they had to of course Spirit it that
way of course um and that's the thing with Corp
I mean corporations I mean they're like What's
the bottom line we got to make as much money as
possible and like so I mean from that perspective
yes it is a movie thing but also too like I could
see a corporation doing what they did in this film
like no no no we're going to rush it I don't care
if it's like yeah we got the guarantee on the
fiveyear but no we're rushing this right now I
saw how intelligent this thing rush rush rush
ask questions later don't care about lawsuits
or anything of that matter no rush it don't
care about mistakes so I could totally see
that every opioid company yeah yeah totally but
um I I appreciated like you know a lot of times
when we watch films like this you don't usually
care about the human characters and obviously
there were some extremely rotten human characters
which is a credit to the actors I thought they all
did a very good job but there were some human
characters I really did care for I like James
Franco and again it was the relationship between
him and James Franco having said that already I
did like the personal element that he had for
it wasn't just I want to make money and I'm a
scientist so I'm going to do no it's his F his
father had Alzheimer's so there was a personal
touch here and why he was doing this and then
you know this ape came into his life and then
there was another personal element to this uh now
you know after he'd lost his father you know now
he was all about protecting you know his son
if you will so I actually appreciate the the
character elements you had the best of humanity
and then you had the worst of humanity so again
you get the distinction there of that uh so I I
actually I really like James Franco I thought he
gave a very good performance in this film and I
I like the character as well and also too I think
Caesar is one of the greatest wingmen of all time
in my opinion like him hooking him up with one of
the hottest veterinarians I've ever seen ever by
the way y um good looking yeah I mean I didn't
I'm not going to lie they didn't really go too
much into it which is fine um I didn't care too
much about the relationship which I didn't need to
the film's not really about that um because they
didn't really spend too much time with those two
yeah not a big deal I think the one line that they
did give her which um I was glad about is that
she said something like not everything is meant
to change uh and she was talking about the 113 and
how like badly it progressed um but also the same
thing like right after his dad died is when that
line came out of not everything is is meant to to
change and I think that um he uh obviously sitting
there and have learned that with his 112 being
probably the the fine enough virus to have helped
for the fiveyear uh stent of time would have
helped a lot of people um and uh I also really
like the relationship with John Lithgow in it
because that was the first time that we saw Caesar
being super protective over a human being because
in the beginning his dad was saying I don't
think he would ever hurt me and his Veterinary
girlfriend I forget her name forgive meot um
that's good enough was like Hey listen he's not
going to be like this for long he's going to get
larger and dangerous so I always love it when they
add in a female and she's not stupid so was very
glad about that that none of it was exposition of
just like what is he doing or why are we here
she was only giving him more information which
was great um but then also uh right after that we
saw Caesar being put into a position to protect
John Lithgow which was his granddad and then you
know sadly he he died you know shortly after that
while Caesar was being removed from him but I
think Caesar's upbringing and being protective
over the humans that that brought him up gave him
a way of leading the Apes that was different than
any of the other Apes could have learned which is
why he was able to succeed with the way that he
was taught and trained even by a scientist which
is kind of built in this movie they're not so good
because they're testing on these animals and they
could be hurting them but there are some small
things that he did learn from home that he taught
to them with the cookies and the sign language
right ended up um saving them all to be able to
rise so there's there's a bit of a j position
that they put you in between the azl 112 and 113
although the Apes would not have been able to
break out and actually rise without it yeah so um
it's like yeah maybe the 113 can can help the Apes
I don't know why we would need all of the Apes out
there to be super intelligent and be talking that
could pose a danger um but it it does prove to us
to pull the the research back and not obviously
Force the 113 stick with the 112 get to people
for 5 years yeah no it's a good point you make I
mean human com compassion and emotion went a long
way especially in Caesar's case uh obviously too
it was so tragic and sad when he felt like James
Franco just left him there and he felt abandoned
and then you saw him like cross out the the window
uh cuz that was you know that was a safe place and
then he'd been torn away literally for that and
what he felt like hey I was just protecting my
grandfather what's happening now and uh then
like again uh now he felt like hey this is my
faction now and now I'm going to protect them and
I really like even though he did feel abandoned by
James Franco which again totally understandable I
get it I really appreciate that moment when Koba
like was about to attack James Franco at the very
end and even Caesar did recognize like hey like
I still love you you're still my father you'll
always be my father but this is now my family
and this is now my home even though you and I will
always have that Bond and this relationship will
still like always be you'll still always be in
my heart I still like I really appreciate that
the writers uh included that moment I I really
would have felt cheapened out if they never if
they didn't give us that moment yeah and he also
did the same thing um with the uh I was number
one so glad that the blonde guy died with uh a
taser and the water getting a taste of his own
treatment I could not wait for that that was
one of my most favorite Parts but cecar also
implemented the same um um regard for the brother
when he when he when he puts him in the cage he
interrupts I believe it was Kobo ready or someone
else ready to kill um the brother like the shy uh
attendant of the of the ape zoo or whatever that
he tells him no we're not killing him he's been
good he's just been doing his job really and he's
not being um he's not the one torturing exactly
and I like that he brought in his human nature
side of he recognizes human nature a little bit
better than the the other Apes I think in just
growing up with him so he saved that guy's life
which is really nice um and I don't think he
even met he didn't he was GNA leave the jackass
the blonde jackass from Harry Potter who I hate
he wasn't going to kill him but that guy killed
himself you know like I mean he was just GNA
probably give him the water treatment but he
ended up electrocuting himself so hey man too much
of an ego narcissist for his own good that's what
you get man you can't mess with the Apes uh I was
really glad of the the position this put movie put
me in I love it I mean I I give it like an eight
and a half I I I loved it I was sick to my stomach
for a lot of those parts but they kind of have
to put you in that position to really care really
love um these apes and where we're at and and the
ending was was great and super Bittersweet and it
was really nice to just see them out in the wild
looking over the city uh to where they came from
um and hopefully they'll be be able to live in
those redwoods safely for at least for till the
next film right uh um yeah I would probably go
like an eight out of 10 uh the story The the car
the emotional stuff again with Caesar and James
Franco and John litho and all the other uh Apes
uh I really the pacing and the uh the music by
Patrick Doyle the cinematography appreciated
so much of this film and uh just really good
uh setup for the next film really curious to
see where uh where we go from here because you
totally could end it here and I'm satisfied but
I obviously have heard how amazing uh the next
two films are uh so I'm curious yeah I'm curious
to see and obviously I'm such a huge fan of Matt
Reeves and the Batman and I know he directed the
next two so I am extremely anxious to see where we
go from here yeah so leave a like leave a comment
let us know if you want us to watch the rest of
them hopefully they'll sign us up to do that with
you guys that would be great don't forget to ring
the bell join patreon do all the right things um
we love you guys so much you got any last words
before we get out of here no just great film uh
Andy Circus seriously that moap job that he did
and and the voice I mean he only had a couple
lines but they were so powerful they were great
they were great awesome job Bravo we love you
guys we love this film we hope to get to watch
the rest of them and we will see you on the next
one all right John pick a name any name John
here we go you ready for this Chase Garder
Chase Garder yeah my God chase you know what
you know what you're getting for Christmas this
year chase you are going to get a fence a nice
fence to protect yourself around Invaders yeah
big and tall and to protect yourself that is also
electrified to protect yourself against bugs and
razor wire should like you know uh fall out from
the sky or whatever try and climb over because
think about it like this with a name like Chase
Garder you wouldn't have to run after anyone if
they're just caught on The Wire now yeah yeah and
you get to protect your garden that's right you
can have an electrified fence around your garden
and be completely self-sufficient and never share
with anybody The Best of Both Worlds chase people
keep coming in trying to steal your crop so this
year when Santa comes down your chimney with a
giant fence and hour delaying delivering presents
because he's there for an obnoxious amount of time
and you're wondering like I just want to get back
to my family Santa's been outside it was exciting
at first but now he's overstaying his welcome
because he's been out there building this fence
and now he's running to the store to get some
supplies he forgot about but it's hard to find a
store open on Christmas he's really not capable
without the elves wasn't as prepared for this
fence no as you might he might have hoped what you
don't know about the Santa Claus story is that he
assembles all gifts on site and so yeah you really
really put a wrench in Christmas he kind of takes
credit for a lot of things he doesn't quite do you
know sure sure so Merry Christmas Chase Gardner
love you buddy stay stay safe out [Music] there